die bundesregierung hat als antwort auf
die hohen energiepreise ein sogenanntes
entlastungs paket beschlossen neben dem
neuen euro ticket für schätzungsweise 2
5 milliarden euro wurde auch
vorgeschlagen benzin und diesel zu
subventionieren für 6,6 milliarden euro
wenn das umgesetzt wird bekommen autos
also mehr als doppelt so viel
unterstützung im vergleich zu den öffis
und die kritik ist ganz schön heftig
neben den fragwürdigen einzelheiten des
pakets ist uns aber vor allem eins
aufgefallen das alles ist nicht neu
unser verhältnis zum auto baut
wortwörtlich die welt um uns herum ich
fahre selber gerne auto trotzdem ist es
zeit einzusehen dass uns auto zentrische
städte langsam aber sicher um bringen
sie verschwenden unsere zeit gefährden
unsere gesundheit und kosten uns
unglaublich viel geld für all diese
aussagen gibt es eine menge studien und
lösungsvorschläge wie man es besser
machen kann und genau darum geht es
jetzt um die autofahrer zu entlasten hat
der bundestag eine senkung der energie
steuer auf benzin und diesel beschlossen
jeder haushalt besitzt durchschnittlich
mehr als ein auto in deutschland staus
vollgepackte innenstädte unfälle das
könnte durch weniger autoverkehr
reduziert werden ein anreiz ordentlich
voll zu danken und aufs klima zu
scheißen während in indien und pakistan
geraden die vögel dehydriert vom himmel
fallen viele leute nehmen es nicht war
aber autofahren ist der normalzustand
der default alles in unserer welt ist
darauf ausgerichtet unsere straßen sind
zu einem großteil für autos gemacht klar
aber das muss nicht so sein vor jedem
haus gibt es parkplätze für autos aber
auch das muss nicht so sein diese auto
zentralität sorgt dafür dass wir vom
auto abhängig sind wir haben bei uns im
team leute die ohne ein auto quasi nicht
zur arbeit kommen würden die
öffentlichen verkehrsmittel sind
zeitlich und preislich keine option
hätte ich jetzt beispielsweise ein
verbrenner auto müsste der preis pro
liter benzin bei 4 euro liegen damit es
mit der bahn günstiger wäre meine eltern
in der heimat zu besuchen wo eigentlich
mitten in köln neuer wohnraum hin könnte
entsteht neben meiner wohnung jetzt ein
riesiges parkhaus und mit dem fahrrad
durch köln zu fahren ist praktisch wie
russisch roulette zu spielen
halo ist fahrradweg
aber das sind natürlich anekdotische
beweise deswegen hier mal die
offiziellen zahlen als erstes das
platzproblem für insgesamt knapp 65
millionen autos in deutschland gibt es
160 millionen stellplätze in berlin
brauchen diese so viel platz wie knapp
214 alexander plätze und gerade mal drei
normale parkplätze blockieren praktisch
so viel fläche wie eine 45 quadratmeter
wohnung die stadt köln hat vor kurzem
gezeigt wie viel fläche entsteht wenn
man einfach mal einen parkplatz zur
sitzfläche umbaut 69 menschen zu
befördern kann entweder so oder
so aussehen in düsseldorf macht die
suche nach parkplätzen zwölf prozent des
gesamten verkehrs aus und aus all diesen
gründen möchte amsterdam in den nächsten
drei jahren
11.200 parkplätze abschaffen und wie das
ganze genau aussieht das kann man hier
gut sehen generell finde ich es super
spannend zu sehen was es einem für ein
gefühl gibt wenn 80 oder sogar 90
prozent einer straße nicht nur riesigen
lauten metallkisten gehört
also es wird ganz schön eng was den
platz angeht wenn es aber um unsere
gesundheit geht ist und schon längst die
luft ausgegangen wo autos fahren atmen
wir feinstaub autos imitieren hier
weniger aber auch die verursachen
feinstaub durch reifenabrieb und in
geringerem maße weil seltener benutzt
bremsen luftverschmutzung tötet weltweit
jedes jahr zehn millionen menschen da
denkt man natürlich weltweit gesehen an
fast mochte megastädte im globalen osten
oder süden aber zahlen weisen darauf hin
dass 90 prozent aller menschen
gefährlich verschmutzte luft atmen
hierzu zählen natürlich nicht nur autos
aber die machen sicherlich auch einen
signifikanten anteil aus aber das ist
noch nicht alles ein umstieg vom auto
aufs fahrrad senkt die
wahrscheinlichkeit an einer
herzkrankheit zu sterben um 52% an krebs
um 40 prozent und dabei reden wir gerade
nur über die körperliche gesundheit 40
prozent der befragten einer studie die
länger als 90 minuten zur arbeit pendeln
haben erhöhten stress nach der arbeit
klar auch 90 minuten mit dem fahrrad
oder dem bus sind ätzend aber wenn
städte weniger auto zentral wären könnte
man neuen wohnraum schaffen so haben
menschen vielleicht die möglichkeit
näher an ihren arbeitsplatz zu ziehen
was das wohlbefinden laut der oben
erwähnten studie und knapp 20 prozent
erhöhen würde und dann haben wir noch
gar nicht über die lärmbelästigung
gesprochen in paris wurde festgestellt
dass ein einziger ungedämpft motorroller
reicht um nachts zehntausend menschen zu
wecken
in deutschland fühlen sich drei viertel
der befragten durch verkehrslärm
belästigt bei 55 dezibel nachts und 65
dezibel tagsüber können körperliche aber
vor allem psychische probleme entstehen
nur zum vergleich haben barbarossaplatz
hier in köln in der innenstadt wurden
tagsüber mehr als 75 dezibel
verkehrslärm gemessen und bevor wir es
vergessen wir sind natürlich nicht die
einzigen wesen die unter lärm leiden
tiere betrifft das genauso aber die
können sich nicht beschweren aber
klar autos erfüllen einen sound von a
nach b kommen will sind sie unglaublich
praktisch nach aktuellen zahlen fahren
68 prozent der deutschen mit dem auto
zur arbeit und das ist ja auch kein
wunder nach jahrzehntelangem
subventionen für autos und benzin runter
wirtschaften der bahn und vielen
gebauten straßen er gibt es auch einfach
am meisten sinn für jeden individuell
gesehen also auto zentrische städte
sorgen für weniger platz niedrigere
lebensqualität und vor allem
gesundheitliche probleme physisch und
psychisch und nicht vergessen weniger
auto fahren sorgt ganz nebenbei für
weniger co2 emissionen aber was
eigentlich das frustrierendste an all
dem ist es könnte so einfach sein
wirklich wie genau das zeigen wir gleich
aber vorher wollen wir endlich mal ein
paar mythen aus dem weg räumen die sich
trotz all dieser überwältigenden gründe
für eine neuausrichtung unserer städte
immer noch halten erstens ohne autos in
den innenstädten wird weniger eingekauft
nein tatsächlich gibt es sogar hinweise
darauf dass es genau andersherum ist
eine autofreie innenstadt hat in madrid
für fast zehn prozent mehr ausgaben im
einzelhandel gesorgt und in berlin
nutzen laut einer studie gerade mal
sieben prozent aller kunden das auto zum
einkaufen geschätzt wurde übrigens durch
ladenbetreiber über 20 prozent menschen
kaufen dinge nicht autos mythos nummer
zwei so eine umstrukturierung dauert
sehr lange in den niederlanden hat man
damit immerhin schon in den 60ern
begonnen abgesehen davon dass das ja
eher ein argument dafür ist dass wir
besser früher als später damit anfangen
sollten stimmt es auch einfach nicht das
ist mindestens 40 jahre dauern muss zum
beispiel nach einem zweimonatigen
lockdown haben die bewohner von
barcelona eine komplett andere
innenstadt wieder gefunden auf einmal
waren bestimmte straßen autofrei es gab
neue und klar ausgewiesene fahrradwege
in zehn jahren will man die küstenstadt
nach eigener aussage von autos befreien
zehn jahre in dieser zeit sollen 60
prozent der straßen zu citizen spaces
werden und weil ein cooler begriff nicht
genug ist die stadt redet von tactical
urbanism also fußgänger und
fahrradfreundlich mehr grün und
idealerweise hat niemand mehr als 200
meter zum nächsten platz oder park zu
laufen
wo wir gerade darüber sprechen welche
pläne städte für die zukunft zu haben
eine moderne und damit auch nachhaltige
stadt zu planen ist gar nicht so einfach
und wenn du dieses video hier gerade
chance ist die chance ziemlich hoch dass
du dich in deiner stadt befindet aktuell
leben fast 80 prozent aller deutschen in
städten das macht das thema für viele
von euch sehr relevant und den partner
dieses videos umso wichtiger denn unsere
städte müssen in zukunft nachhaltiger
und ökologischer werden da führt kein
weg dran vorbei das urban land institute
kurz setzt sich hier als vermittler
zwischen der privaten
immobilienwirtschaft und der
öffentlichen stadtplanung 1 mit ihrem
programm erben plan wollen sie jungen
menschen zeigen wie sie die entwicklung
unserer städte selbst mitgestalten
können und welche spannenden
berufsfelder ist da gibt und so ein
planspiel sieht so aus wir müssen uns
jetzt hier überlegen wie wir ein
stadtviertel planen und dabei
verschiedene gebäude hier hinsetzen und
überlegen wie passt das alles zusammen
denn es gibt unglaublich viele kriterien
die wir beachten müssen sozialen
wohnungsbau finanzierung müssten am ende
noch gewinn erwirtschaften das ganze
natürlich nett seinen schön aussehen wir
wollen grünflächen bauen und es macht
tatsächlich sehr viel spaß
auf der seite von julia erfahrt ihr mehr
darüber welche herausforderungen einen
job in der stadtentwicklung mit sich
bringt und wie ihr da überhaupt rein
kommt dazu könnt ihr euch unis
hochschulen oder unternehmen ansehen die
den einstieg in die branche ermöglichen
wenn ihr also lust und interesse habt
euch über mögliche berufe in der
stadtentwicklung und oder der
immobilienbranche zu informieren oder
einfach mehr über dieses wirklich
wichtige thema wissen wollt dann schaut
mal beim juli vorbei und klickt auf den
ersten link unten in der video
beschreibung und jetzt geht es weiter
mit mythos nummer drei aber das ist doch
so teuer klar so große pläne kosten geld
aber wenn wir wieder in die niederlande
schauen sieht man das ein jährliches
investment von einer halben milliarde
dollar in die fahrrad infrastruktur
jährlich 19 milliarden dollar einsparen
die sonst vom gesundheitswesen und
anderen bereichen ausgegeben worden
wären noch mal jährlich 1 38 fache
return on investment ist eigentlich nur
durch kriminelle aktivitäten oder am
crypto machbar dazu kommt straßen müssen
er regelmäßig neu gebaut werden das
erklärt auch warum können quasi eine
einzige baustelle ist ab circa 30 jahren
hat eine straße ihr lebensende erreicht
und ein umbau muss so oder so
stattfinden warum dann nicht einfach mal
mit besseren fahrradwegen im hinterkopf
und mal ganz abseits davon es gibt auch
vorteile zum beispiel lebensqualität die
sich zumindest nicht direkt in geld
aufwiegen lassen aber langfristig allen
etwas bringen auch der konjunktur
mythos nummer vier aber der verkehr ist
doch ohnehin schon schlimm was wenn wir
jetzt die gleiche belastung auf weniger
straßen um routen also erstmal geht es
natürlich nicht darum autos einfach zu
verbannen sondern darum andere
verkehrsmittel zu verbessern aber selbst
dann alles bleibt die zuvor gibt es hier
tatsächlich ein richtig spannendes
phänomen es klingt paradox aber mehr
straßen sorgen nicht für besseren
verkehr tatsächlich ist es andersherum
mehr straßen sorgen für mehr verkehr das
ganze nennt sich in new zealand und wenn
ihr mehr darüber erfahren wollt dann
schaut euch doch mal diese studie hier
an
und damit kommen wir auch schon zu den
letzten drei punkten und die sind nicht
so wirklich mieten sondern
wahrscheinlich tatsächlich war erstens
in der stadt ist das vielleicht alles
easy und logisch aber in ländlichen
regionen ist man auf das auto angewiesen
und hier kann man nur sagen ja das
stimmt aber wenn wir schon früher mehr
in eine gute öffentliche anbindung
investiert hätten wären wir heute
vielleicht nicht hier deswegen besser
früher als später umdenken und dann
kommt oft noch das argument dass bessere
infrastruktur dann eh nicht genutzt
werden würde und jetzt habe ich mal eine
sehr schöne analogie gelesen die anzahl
der menschen die gerade durch einen
fluss schwimmen ist kein guter indikator
für die anzahl der menschen die eine
brücke benutzen würden
und tatsächlich konnte man zum beispiel
in paris ein sehr starkes wachstum der
fahrradfahrer feststellen nachdem die
infrastruktur für fahrräder auch endlich
mal gut ausgebaut wurde quellen zu allen
aussagen findet übrigens wie immer unten
in der video beschreibung verlinkt
kommen wir zum letzten mythos der
wahrscheinlich gar keiner ist wenn
städte nicht mehr auf autos ausgerichtet
sind werden die gründe ein auto zu
kaufen immer weniger und da kann ich nur
sagen nein auch viele klimaforscher
würde mir da wahrscheinlich zustimmen
trotzdem ist das natürlich kurz und
mittelfristig mega blöd für beschäftigte
in und um die automobilbranche das muss
man auch verstehen aber generell ist der
vorwurf das auto abschaffen zu wollen
glaube ich ein großes missverständnis
der mobilitäts wende es geht nicht darum
autos abzuschaffen sondern einfach nicht
mehr notwendig zu machen der sehr gute
youtube-kanal logistics hat das wie ich
finde genial zusammengefasst es wird
immer autos geben ihr werdet
wahrscheinlich immer die freiheit haben
auto zu fahren aber was ist mit der
freiheit nicht auto fahren zu müssen
dieser satz hat sich bei mir eingebrannt
und der gilt wie ich finde vor allem für
leute auf dem land anstatt sich zu
fragen warum die benzinpreise höher und
höher werden und wieso die politik
nichts für die pendler tut die auf ihr
auto angewiesen sind fragt euch doch mal
lieber was ist mit unserem recht nicht
auf das auto angewiesen zu sein
[Musik]
also worauf warten wir auch wenn es
manchmal nicht so scheint bewegen wir
uns schon ein wenig in die richtige
richtung ein teil der lösung um die
städte den verkehr und unsere gesundheit
zu retten könnten autofreie innenstädte
seien und viele städte in nrw wollen
zumindest teilweise autofrei werden aber
das stößt oft auf gegenwind von
anwohnern und vor allem vom einzelhandel
in der heimatstadt unseres
redaktionsleiters wurde per
bürgerabstimmung einen fahrradstreifen
nur ein fahrradstreifen auf der
hauptstraße verhindert aus angst dass
die fehlenden parkplätze im einzelhandel
den rest geben würden und das spiegelt
sich auch in einer großen umfrage aus
dem letzten jahr wieder business insider
hat herausgefunden dass 66 prozent der
deutschen auto freie innenstädte
ablehnen dies ist aber wichtig zu
erwähnen dass die zustimmung für
autofreie innenstädte mit der
besiedlungsdichte steigt fragt man die
leute in gegenden mit sehr hoher
besiedlungsdichte stimmt schon die
hälfte der idee zu
woran das liegt da kann man natürlich
nur spekulieren aber zwischen großstadt
und dort gibt es in meiner erfahrung
einen deutlichen unterschied was die
verfügbarkeit und verlässlichkeit von
öffentlichen verkehrsmitteln angeht eine
stadt die so ein bisschen zeigt in
welche richtung ist zumindest in den
nächsten jahren gehen könnte ist
bielefeld jaja ich weiss die stadt gibt
es eigentlich gar nicht haha blablabla
aber mal im ernst was die stadt seit
letztem jahr macht ist tatsächlich
ziemlich interessant seit mitte juni
2021 ist die altstadt autofrei und da wo
man parkbuchten waren sind jetzt tische
stühle und pflanzen was man ganz
nebenbei auch dem umsatz von restaurants
erhöht außerdem wurden 50 einwohnern
letztes jahr 1000 euro angeboten wenn
sie ihr auto abmelden der plan ist das
ganze auch für eine breitere masse
anzubieten sofern es erfolgreich ist
aber selbst noch mal nicht dauerhaft
verzichten will gibt es eine 400 euro
prämie wenn man sein auto mindestens
drei monate stehen lässt
aber ist das genug wahrscheinlich nicht
wie eben schon erwähnt müssen wir die
alternativen zum auto attraktiver machen
dahingehend ist das geplante neue euro
ticket ein sehr guter erster ansatz
ersetzt aber natürlich nicht
langfristige investitionen in den ausbau
von guter öffentliche anbindung für
jeden egal ob großstadt oder dorf dieses
video ist ein blick in die stadt der
zukunft wenn wir uns als gesellschaft
entscheiden nicht alles um das auto
herum zu planen aber die zukunft wird
noch mehr als eine mobilität spende in
diesem video hier haben uns mal
angeschaut was ich noch alles in den
nächsten jahrzehnten ändern wird und
vielleicht auch ändern muss wir sehen
uns nächste woche wieder zu einem ganz
besonderen video ich kann nur so viel
verraten wenn ihr es bis hierhin in
dieses video geschafft habt wo das
nächste woche sehr spannend bis dahin
bleibt
neugierig